absolutely I am here with the executive
director of the Saint Louis chess club
Tony Tony uh please tell us a little bit
about this situation that is developing
in the Chess World with one of the
players here at the USS Champion ship
Hans Limerick oh Hansel
okay uh yeah so uh during the singfield
cup uh Magnus Carlson is everybody knows
withdrew from the event
um subsequently has accused tons of
cheating uh in chess there was a report
that came out from chess.com just
yesterday in fact that details some of
that cheating uh specifically in online
chess play and draw some questions about
some of his over-the-board play as well
and what is the official position right
now of the Saint Louis chess club
related to this drama
well
um
you know Jonathan Ralston sent out a a
tweet earlier that I thought kind of
sums it up nicely has Hans cheated over
the board uh we don't know cert for
certain has he cheated online yes
admittedly he has do we still have to
assume that he's innocent until he's
proven guilty and the answer to that is
yes so uh if and until U.S chess or fide
or some other authoritative governing
body decides to investigate and take
action
um it behooves organizers to lead
players and and let them play their
events and I think it's worth mentioning
that the contracts and the invitations
for this USS championships have been
sent long time ago can you talk about
the selection process as well a little
bit sure so the U.S Championship field
is really determined by July that's when
the rating lists come out that the event
is based on so um from from that
perspective you're right Hans was
already signed and ready to go before
the singfield cup started I can also say
that the chess club doesn't um we don't
have the authority to select players for
the national championships we submit a
bid to the U.S trust Federation and U.S
chess is responsible for determining how
players can make it into the event
typically players make it in by rating
and through qualifying events we do have
one wild card in the U.S Championship
this year and that was our pick that's a
Wonder Liang but Hans qualified to play
the U.S championship by winning the 2021
U.S junior Championship and I actually
called that tournament as well and I
remember it was an incredible
performance by Hanzo definitely deserved
to be here in the U.S Chess Championship
and also we've seen that the measures
the anti-cheating measures have been
strengthened at the St Louis chess club
talk about that a bit sure obviously we
wanted to ensure that our events are
held with the highest Integrity possible
we want to ensure fair play across all
the tournaments I want the players to
feel comfortable knowing that when they
come to play in St Louis that we take it
very seriously so for example this year
we've implemented additional security
measures we we've always had the metal
detecting wands we've added to that the
radio frequency scanners that check for
any signaling that's happening in the
room we've implemented additional
scanners that check for any silicon
devices so that would be any Electronics
on a person regardless of whether
they're powered on or off regardless of
whether they're transmitting a signal or
not these devices would detect that
electronic So Physical scanning we also
have the game analysis by Ken Reagan
which he continues to provide for us and
in addition to that we've implemented a
30 minute delay on this broadcast
all of those things combined uh adding
to that the fact that no Spectators are
allowed in the playing Hall the only
folks in there right now are the players
the Arbiters the events staff and select
media any media that's present in the
playing Hall is always accompanied by
chess club staff they too must leave
their electronic devices out of the
playing hole so I really believe that
we've implemented uh some best of breed
practices here in this tournament Tony I
think that pretty much clears the air
thank you very much for joining the show
and well you have a lot of work to do so
good luck in that thank you a quick
question for you Tony because I get this
a lot a lot of people ask me
how did the organizers of the Cinco cup
feel when Magnus withdrew did you
how did I feel how did you feel yes well
Yasser he asked all the hard questions
um
do I think it was appropriate for Magnus
to withdraw from the singfield cup no
um do I think the fact that he withdrew
from the sinkfield cup has drawn
attention to a cheating problem that
exists in the Chess World yes
did that answer your question yes sir
pretty much just wanted and the feedback
also is the St Louis chess club Rex
everybody's committed to further
tournaments including the sync Phil Cup
this wasn't like a death blow to to the
sink fill cup
thank you Tori
thank you Tony indeed and by the way
we've already had one